well I don't think I can do a better
introduction than the bat for Donna but
it is my pleasure to introduce to
everyone Donna dibinsky who without her
support for Yale tech none of these
conferences would be possible she's been
an amazing facilitator bringing together
the Yale tech community but in her
actual day job she is currently the CEO
and co-founder of New benta which she'll
spend some time talking about today but
she previously found it handspring and
served the CEO of palm she earned her BA
from Yale University and her MBA from
Harvard Business School and currently
sits on the board of Yale University so
hand it over back to Donna okay Thank
You Victor let me start by saying I'm
battling a cold and usually you can hear
me in the next County but I'm struggling
a little with my voice so I'll do the
best I can but forgive me if I need to
sip water and so on as I try to get
through that so when I chatted with
Victor about what to talk about today i
decided i would tackle a topic i haven't
done before so I'm trialing this out on
you guys you can let me know later if it
works or not but I've been thinking a
bit about my career being this career on
the edge of technology and and what does
that mean and what have been the good
parts and the bad parts about picking a
career along those dimensions so that's
what I was going to talk about so what
do I mean by that well let me give you
my credentials in this regard I asked
Victor and they're not going the details
so that i could and first i went to
apple very early on 1981 and at the time
the notion of one computer one person
was absolutely extraordinary it was
inconceivable at that time computers
were in raised floor lock computer rooms
accessible only to computer experts and
not normal people and that's just not
what computers were and it's so hard to
put yourself back in that mindset from
from that time but it was a very radical
notion as a result there there was
nothing there for it there were no
suppliers for the components to build
these computers there were no dealers my
first job was in distribution and we
pretty much create
ated this retail distribution network
there was there was nothing like that
that existed before there were no people
that had experienced it was you know if
you hired people you hire people who had
never worked at the computer industry
before there was no software there was
no application so really it was a
situation where you were definitely out
there on the edge then the second time I
did this was I went from there to palm
and palm was in roughly the same
situation the idea of a computer in your
pocket again totally radical couldn't
imagine that anybody was going to be
able to do this it was inconceivable
there weren't components to build the
Palm Pilot I'll tell you one quick story
we wanted to display obviously for the
Palm Pilot those of you who remember it
it was a monochrome display before they
made color displays that small and we
had a huge problem finding somebody to
build us this display because we went to
the regular display manufacturers and
like no that's a small black and white
display we're building big color
displays we're not interested and we we
really struggled with this till finally
we hit upon the idea of going into guys
who are making the displays for pagers
remember the little pagers they were
small monochrome displays and then Wow a
big monochrome display that's it that's
a big opportunity for us to move
upstream so we'll do that and we got
them in the business of doing those
displays same thing with memories same
things with other components there just
simply weren't components for that
product there wasn't any it wasn't clear
what the distribution strategy would be
should we go through consumer
electronics players should we go through
those computer dealers the computer
dealers weren't interested in these
little tiny things because they were
lower cost the consumer electronics guys
were like oh this is a computer we're
scared of that we don't want to do that
so they're really it was hard to find
what was the right distribution channel
for this there was no software no apps
same thing and again no experts to hire
you couldn't go out and find the world's
expert in marketing handheld computers
when nobody had ever built a handheld
computer before then the third time I
did it was at handspring and in that
case we said we're going to connect
these things to the world we're going to
make
them smartphones and we started out with
a kind of a slot where we plug phones
into them and we said that's we're going
to do well same set of issues they're
back again on components I mean the
radios to buy a radio to put into the
early handspring and trio products was
extremely difficult i mean people hardly
made this easy found one company in
France that was making these radios for
people to embed in products and that was
it i mean we scoured the world and these
radios had lots and lots of quality
problems in the beginning so it was very
difficult to get the components to build
this stuff the data networks were
totally immature I mean we have these
you know incredible data network say
this is before Wi-Fi this is before you
could actually do data over the cell
your net cellular network so we were
dealing with kind of stealing little
data channels from the boys networks and
it was extremely difficult to be able to
use this stuff on the data networks at
the time there was the distribution was
a huge problem there's a carrier
stranglehold he had to go through the
carrier's which was extremely difficult
and challenging to work with those guys
they were basically Public Utilities
trying to morph into businesses and they
were I could tell you lots of stories
about that extremely difficult to work
with so very hard to establish
distribution and once again there were
no experts to hire I mean if you you
know we found one guy who had experience
with GSM radio it's like oh my gosh I
remember you know paying this guy like a
fortune because you know to find a guy
who actually had experience with this
sort of stuff was just amazing so very
very challenging and then now I'm doing
new menta and I feel like I'm kind of
back in the same thing we're working on
intelligent computing these are
computers that learn the same way you
learn and your brain learns it's based
on biology so we need people who
understand biology and neuroscience as
well as computer science and you know
it's hard to find those people and it's
not clear what the applications are
we're trying out a bunch of applications
we've proven out some things it's very
interesting it's very important but it's
still early and it's hard to imagine
what
these applications are going to be as
that rolls out so very difficult time oh
one of the other big challenges with new
menta is that the way your brain
operates and the way our technology
operates is on streaming data so data
flowing through time if you think about
sensors that the data they put out as
opposed to databases or how do poor
things like that and most companies say
they have this kind of data but when you
actually get into the detail you find
they don't really have this kind of data
so there's going to be a conversion from
these spatially oriented database
approach to data in motion temporal
streaming data and we're just starting
that conversion reminds me very much of
dealing with the carriers and the
problems of getting data over the
cellular networks so these are very
comparable problems that I've seen you
know time and time again after a very
many years in this in this industry so
so how do I could characterize some of
these challenges well first there's just
no roadmap it's not like you can look
and say what have others done and I'm
going to just do it a little better I'm
going to do what those guys did but
faster but smarter but more creatively
better branding whatever I mean it's
kind of the way people call the uber of
X now I'm going to do the uber of
whatever where you have a clear model
and you just follow that model tweak it
a little and off you go you don't have
that these are all discovery kind of
opportunities you have no suppliers I
people forget about this they focus so
much on customers that they forget about
how hard it can be to find suppliers who
can provide you with the materials you
need to create the product you're trying
to create likewise there's no
infrastructure so every single time we
had distribution challenges we had
communications challenges was hard to
talk to your audience it just every
single time we were dealing with massive
infrastructure problems and you need to
be flexible you know you're going to
make errors you just don't know which
ones are going to make and so what you
tried to do is figure out all right I'm
going to take a shot at this thing but
if i'm wrong i want to make sure i limit
the damage and i can change when i
figure out I'm wrong so you start to
view things very much from the land
of flexibility as opposed to absolute
what's the right answer what's the wrong
answer because you know you're going to
have to make some errors along the way
very hard to hire you end up looking to
basic strengths intellect skills not
expertise I just really could have cared
less and pretty much all these companies
whether somebody had the specific
expertise I was looking for I was really
looking for talent and you can find
analogies I remember in our early sales
force at Apple many of the early sales
reps were from the old electronic
distributions network they'd sold
electronics things they'd sold them a
new distributors but they had no
experience with computers and they don't
experience with consumer products but we
could train them on that they knew they
had selling skills they knew they could
learn about electronics and so you find
an analogy and you hire from there as
opposed to looking for people with
exactly those skills so those are the
challenges what about the rewards why
bother why do this isn't it much easier
to just figure out something you do just
tweak and get it out there well first I
have to start with the fact that the
financial rewards are much greater so
biggest risk biggest rewards classic
risk/reward curve upper right biggest
risk biggest reward so that's no doubt
if you want to get wealthy that's the
way to do it however you may get zero so
you have to be prepared for the fact
that that that's that's the gamble
they're so eager risk bigger reward but
there are an awful lot of incredible
rewards outside of the financial rewards
and and I think it's really important to
understand those first it's incredibly
creative I mean you get to solve really
hard problems and there's just no answer
sheet for them so you have to figure
them out I remember we had this problem
once with the trio where it was failing
it just was failing over and over again
a quality problem and we just couldn't
figure it out and we you know looked at
this problem we looked at this one we
looked at this problem we just couldn't
figure it out finally I said that's it
we're getting everybody in the room i
got the hardware guy the software God
the manufacturing got the somebody from
every
single function the best I had in the
company said I locked the door we are
not leaving this room until we figure
out what this problem is and it turned
out that literally we had put on the
back of the case with a door for the
batteries we put a sticker on the
battery door and it be created enough
friction that it disconnected the
batteries from the connectors when it
went in which lost a software patch that
had fixed an earlier problem such that
then the computer failed it was just
amazing and but it took actually
somebody would knowledge of
manufacturing with knowledge of hardware
and we knowledge of software to figure
out those things working together as
well created that problem but you know
solving those kind of problems was just
really a lot of fun you know just giant
puzzles if you can solve them and then I
would say that the people are very fun
risk tech risk takers tend to be very
fun very lively very interesting people
sometimes a little crazy you have to get
used to dealing with sometimes a little
crazy people but I for one have a very
broad acceptance of a lot of different
types of people and you find them in
these types of endeavors and that's
that's been very satisfying for me and I
think that just the notion of how hard
it is to make it work then when you
succeed it's that much more satisfying
so it's when things are easy you can be
a big success and pat yourself on the
back i remember when hands bring was
really going great i thought it was you
know the most brilliant CEO in the world
then you know when we ran into problems
and i had to get us out of them I
suddenly had a new realization which was
that this is actually when the really
great CEOs proved themselves is getting
out of the hard problems as opposed to
the ones that just ride the wave when
times are good so I think that the
notion of accepting bigger challenge and
getting bigger satisfaction is something
that's always appealed to me but the
biggest one by far in my book is just
impact is that knowing what you're
working on can really impact people's
lives in a positive way I mean
everything I've worked on has over these
four different
waves of computing has helped make
computing tools more and more accessible
to more and more people to solve more
and more problems and to me I still get
a thrill every time I see somebody with
a smartphone which is every now and then
and know that I was part of the
foundational group that made that happen
and that's just been an incredible thing
to be a part of for a career so very
worthwhile so what are those things
today well i'm sure you guys all have
ideas about what those things are today
and i'm sure that you're right about
some of them i find it amusing when I
hear people say oh the future is mobile
the futures mobiles and no no the thing
was to figure out that the future was
mobile 20 years ago before it was
obvious you know we were working on
mobile dead and nobody thought the
future was mobile everybody thought we
were totally crazy so the idea that now
you're saying the future is mobile you
can ask a bigger thing well that is not
yet that was it but that is not it now
the question is what is it over the next
10 years or the next 20 years that's not
obvious today that's the way to get
involved in that leading edge so clearly
I think one of these things is
intelligent computing we've seen a lot
of activity on this and just the last
year or two we've been working on it for
over 10 years everything in this field
takes a long time I think we're making a
stunning progress so I'm very excited
and I think that there's going to be
whole new businesses built on top of
this lots and lots of opportunities of
things that one can do with this
technology that simply can't be done
today so I'm very excited about that
because that's clearly what I'm in the
middle of but I think there's others as
well I'm very excited about 3d printing
I think 3d printing is going to create
all sorts of new opportunities of
building things on demand and creating
things you never could have created
before I think drones are very
interesting I can imagine all sorts of
new businesses that come out of the idea
that you could take a different look at
the world and you can take a look at the
world now I think the whole biomedical
area is absolutely fascinating I know
it's a tough area I'm no expert in it I
no regulatory is very challenging but I
think that data science and genetics and
personal
as medicine in all these areas are going
to create enormous opportunities in that
field as well so for the people who say
oh it's all over or it's all we're going
to do is build yet another way to order
food on a mobile app I just want to
encourage if we have a lot of ways I
think having people in their 20s all
creating companies is a really wonderful
thing but we don't need more ways to get
food get dates and get rides we are well
served we are really well served so I
urge you to think about these other
areas that are not so obvious that are
harder and that are higher risk and
potentially higher reward so those are
my comments and I try to leave time for
questions which i think i did so i'm
happy to take any questions for you talk
about something less means that you'll
earn from working at home and answering
now that's currently like the same thing
no you run
lessons that I've learned well I have
whole talks on this that take multiple
hours so I've been thinking I should
write a book on this but haven't gotten
around to it well one is absolutely to
defy conventional wisdom I have spent
all of my career to find conventional
wisdom whenever anybody says you can't
do this because of something or other
you have to do it this way it just goes
in one ear and out the other I don't
even listen to it anymore and it's it's
so common so so common I'll tell you an
apple story actually that was one of my
favorites early in the Apple days when
we was running distribution we put in
this thing a policy called price
protection because dealers would have
all this inventory and the price of a
product would go down and they'd have
this inventory so we would protect their
inventory given the amount of it so I
established this I research did I put in
place so on well then several years
later I decided to change it for summary
and something happened differently and
you know somebody said to me but we've
always had price protection it's always
been this way this is the way we have to
do like no no what I made that policy
here's why I did it here's what's
changed and here's why we need to change
the policy I mean I just I was just so
amazed how people get in these mindsets
that we have to do it this way because
it's always been done this way so that
is is probably one of the biggest themes
of what all those things tie together
and I mean I could give you a lot more
but let me just stop with one other
things yes over there
can you repeat that one more time sure
she wasn't very complimentary about
Hadoop understandably so I'm wondering
for streaming data and data in motion
what technologies are using and if any
of them are open source and also in
terms of your great leaps forward in
intelligent computing if you could
narrow it down to say the last 12 months
can you talk about what opened the door
to a great look forward but it was a
technology was it a shift in
understanding what was it well I did not
mean to be disparaging Hadoop at all I
think what I was trying to do is
differentiate what we do from the world
of big data that as we know it today the
world of big data as we know it today is
very focused on big databases and that's
what the hadoop world is and many other
technologies we are focused on streaming
data which is very different than that
so it was more to distinguish the one
from the other in terms of the leap
forward my partner Jeff was really the
product person not me he is really the
only way that you can phrase it he is
reverse engineering the neocortex he is
really trying to understand what the
different layers do what the neurons do
what the actual all the little bits and
pieces in there do it's extraordinary
and where we first started was
understanding what one layer in the
brain does and we've got one layer of
the six layers where we really have
modeled that and understand that which
has to do with streaming data and making
a model of the world now the next part
of the theory that he's working on which
is some major breakthroughs in just in
the past 12 months has to do with the
integration of behavior with that
streaming data so a lot of the way you
learn your brain learns and our software
learns is by motion so the other object
is moving in the world you see a dog
running and and that helps you learn
about that dog and recognize that dog
you learn from movies not from stills
but also you move so your hands move on
things and and and that's how you
recognize an object your eyes are always
moving it's called a saccade you are
always moving in the world and objects
are always moving in the world and the
intersection of those and how that
impacts of streaming data is how you
form a model the world
you can understand the world that's what
the theory of intelligence is about so
he is now incorporating these multiple
motion sets and mapping them against the
actual neocortex so it's pretty stunning
we'll see what the applications of that
I'm not entirely sure yet but what is
his name again Jeff Hawkins and this is
a we are and you asked about open source
let me just say that at new mentor we
actually have all of our technology and
open source so you can go on new mentor
org if you're a technically inclined
person and see everything that we're
working on we also publish papers we've
just had a new paper published that's
extremely biological for those of you
who are biologically inclined that I
think is going to come to be a huge
paper in the field very important paper
in the field so I urge you to look at
that
okay so it is a little unusual to be
standing and firm you having had a whole
career tech with a history major from
Yale so definitely unusual I got
fortunate that I got into the industry
early so I there weren't you didn't find
experts as i said in my opening remarks
so you know they had to hire people who
weren't necessarily experts I went out
of my way to understand this stuff as
best as I could within my limits I'll
give you an example i started at Apple
in the logistics area and I signed up
for the service tech course I wasn't
going to be a service tech you know but
I said that's how i'm going to
understand what's in this thing and we
took about computers we learned how to
do it did disk drive calibrations i did
all this sort of stuff went through the
whole service tech course just because i
wanted to understand as much as I could
about what the heck was in this thing
when i joined up with um Jeff at Palm he
had one patent and I said alright that
seems to be a core asset for our new
company so I'm going to understand that
patent so I read that patent well those
of you who aren't used to reading
patents you know reading a patent is
really hard to understand what it is
saying so what i did is i sat down with
jeff and i said okay i've read this pad
here's what I think it says tell me if
I'm right and say yeah you're mostly
right but you're a little bit wrong and
here's where you're wrong and this is
what it means and I just kept just kept
repeating repeating repeating until I
understood it in my words in my
framework and I continue to do that to
this day I mean the work we're doing I
understand only so far I understand it
more than any other non technical person
believe me I could tell you more about
the brain than you can imagine but I do
not understand it to the degree that the
technical people do but I understand
it's a degree that I need to understand
it so I think that's possible for
anybody but it takes work and diligence
and and learning and and definitely
effort in terms of your second question
what's the right time to leave well I'm
not sure I could generalize I mean for
me each circumstance was I was one very
different than the other what graduated
and went to apple
I had seen a demo of an apple to at
business school and I'd seen it running
busy calc and I like 20 i mean the light
bulb went off I just said that is
amazing that was the first spreadsheet
I'd done spreadsheets by hand as a
banker and I was like I just got to go
work for that company because that is
important that is important and so I
figured that out and I harass them until
they gave me a job that was I mean it
wasn't a start-up but it wasn't a very
big company so it was a pretty early
stage company at the time Apple was I
went from apple and an apple then we
created Claire us and then after claris
apple bought us back and I left because
I wanted to be in a smaller
entrepreneurial companies I didn't want
to go back to Apple I took a year off I
went to Paris claris to Paris made sense
and learn french and then I I went
through a very deliberate process where
I said I want to be a CEO I want to be
at a startup company what do I know I
literally did a balance sheet what am I
asked that's one of my liabilities what
do I know what don't I know what do I
need to figure out us fear I'm very
analytical sometimes I should have been
an engineer and and I realized that I
had pretty much all the functions
covered except for I wasn't a
technologist I wasn't an engineer I
didn't know really how to do that stuff
so I came back specifically looking for
a partner that was those things who I
could partner with where I could bring
the rest of the things and start a
company and that's when I met Jeff and
then the whole palm story won't go into
it's too tedious and 22 what a roller
coaster anyway we ended up leaving palm
because of various corporate Massa
nations and starting the new company
handspring and eventually handspring was
acquired so each one was kind of a
different story so I'm not sure I can
generalize more I think Allison said it
well and you know you kind of know it
when you get there and when it's time to
go you you know you need to go you know
you do is staying longer usually doesn't
help so I think she said it well if not
further question from Melinda thanks
thanks for your talk I just wanted to
ask you how you're going to fact
in social behavior because I I work in
healthcare and teach communication and
we know that 70 over seventy percent of
the safety and quality problems in
healthcare that customers are really
motivated to solve are caused by
communication errors so it's social
behavior but it's not really about
moving in space it's about relationships
with each other and in communication
well that's kind of a complex question I
mean we're not we're not trying to
create a human brain we're trying to
create kind of an analytical engine
that's a learning machine learns from
its sensory data that's modeled after
your neocortex your old brain has a lot
of your social activities we're not
doing that that being said I've had a
reasonable man of encounters with the
healthcare system myself lately and and
there's so much that can be improved
upon that our analytics could help for
example I was just was in the hospital
last weekend with my elderly father and
you know those like all those machines
they hook them up to and how they're
like alarms are going off all the time
and everybody ignores them because
they're going off all the time those are
called false positives well we know how
to fix those we can find real patterns
with our streaming data and we know how
to signal real problems not false
positives and so there are places I
think in the healthcare environment
where we could make a huge difference
we're actually working with a Yale
professor we ran a contest at Yale two
people to try to apply our technology in
the winner of the contest is a a doctor
and teacher and researcher at Yale and
he is he's into a pulmonary medicine and
he's trying to use Apple watch data to
be able to tect early problems with his
pulmonary patients and finding anomalies
in what they're doing based on you know
the streaming date out of the Apple
watch so I think that's very promising
so I think there's areas where we're
going to be able to add value but we're
not we're not replicating emotions we're
not replicating caring we're not
replicating hunger or thirst or any of
those things we are about finding
patterns in the world and understanding
them so we're kind of at a different
layer okay last question from Julie
hi I'm Julie love I recently joined the
board the quantum computing company that
was started by to Yale professors so
your talk about being at the frontier of
computing is really resonating with me I
would love to hear you say more about
how you think about building an
ecosystem around new menta and kind of
you know both from the supplier side but
also you know developers and how you're
going to make sure that that is the
paradigm that goes forward and kind of
how that's change over time you
mentioned open source and the
competition's but love to hear thoughts
on that I just have loved working with
developer communities it's been one of
the greatest joys of my career in each
case we had developer communities at
Apple we had people writing software at
palm we had people writing software I
know everybody thinks Apple invented
apps but actually we had them back in
the palm days handspring you know
enormous number of apps on the trio and
and we do plan to do the same in New
menta the thing about having a platform
in a developer community that's so
rewarding is that they think of things
you never would have thought of I mean
just the number of applications that
clever people come up with in the world
is such a thrill I remembered the Palm
Pilot we had a guy in Africa who was
doing tracking of wild animals on this
thing and it was just like wow whoever
would have thought of that that is so
cool so you know it's really fun to see
what people do with your technology now
at newmont oh we made this decision to
be open source which is is a little bit
unusual in terms of how far we went on
that I mean we just said we're doing our
research in the open you could go into
our research directory so every day to
see what we're working on and and we we
just feel it is such fundamental
technology and so important for the
future of the world in so many different
application areas and it's so hard to
get people up to speed on it it is
really hard material you have to spend
quite a bit of time getting into it to
understand it I just have to warn you
about that it's hard and so we want to
give people the best possible chance and
I think too many people go to extreme in
the control direction it's top secret I
gotta kill you if I will
tell you I mean it's like come on you
know it's it's so hard to convince
people to use your stuff and a training
to use your stuff if your idea is a
little teeny idea that's really easy to
do well yeah you got to keep it secret
because it's really easy to do somebody
else is going to do it but if you're
working on big hard ideas just tell
everybody you can about it because you
know you never know who's going to be
able to help you with it so we've taken
this attitude of we're going to tell
everybody we can about it I love it i've
meetings no NDA's never a problem it's
like you know whatever you want to know
I'll tell you about it and it's
liberating now you might ask let me just
cover this off how do you cook how do
you reconcile that with being in
business and having a business model so
that comes a little bit in the magic of
the different open-source licenses so
the license we picked which is a gplv3
is a polluting license a copyleft
license this means if you use our
software under this license and you
distribute it so you put it in a product
you have to also distribute it under the
a GPL this is kind of toxic to a lot of
companies who don't want to publish
their source code so what happens is it
enables researchers universities anybody
who wants to use it to use it yet what a
commercial entity is using it and they
can start that way they can start on the
a GPL but when they're ready to put it
in a product they come to us for
commercial license and we essentially
let them take a license outside of the a
GPL where they don't have to follow the
a GPL so it's called a dual license
strategy it was pioneered by other
people not us but when we did this
research we came upon this duel license
strategy is kind of the best of both
worlds which is that we're totally open
everybody gets to see everything we're
doing on we can try to get a community
built around our technology which we do
have a growing community built around
our technology and at the same time
still have a commercial licensing
opportunity so I've been really pleased
with that strategy